hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now I know in the last episode I was a
little cataclysmic about all this I was
desperate I was feeling pessimistic
about their chances of survival but I
realized that I can't give up on my
family and I know they're not my real
family but in this game they they might
be clones they might be copies they're
duplicates but their lives are in my
hands and if I have to take
responsibility for this I will so I'm
gonna make sure that they survive and I
have a plan to do it so first off the
main problem is oxygen and carbon
dioxide they're using too much oxygen
they're making too much carbon dioxide
it's poisoning everything down here and
I don't have the means to purify that
just yet that is in advanced filtration
and I don't know there's a few other
research categories that I need to be
able to filter out carbon dioxide with
an air scrubber and that uses a
filtration medium such as sand and I'm
going to get that but for the immediate
future we also need algae and the algae
is actually here there's algae down here
there's algae up here there's a lot of
algae still in this area that can scrub
carbon dioxide to Bias time until we get
there but we need to do a lot of stuff
so it requires a great overhaul of
everything that we got to do and I know
everyone is stressed to the maximum
there's only a few people that are not
stressed so we just need to start over
but right here so the first stage of the
plan is to create tiles around here
start the rooms from the very base
around the portal which already has
decoration to it so that people will
feel less stressed when they're around
the portal and then keep these here but
I'm actually gonna put these at a low
priority compared to everything else
that we're going to do I'm gonna
actually put those down at last priority
I'm not gonna remove them because
eventually I do want those there but not
yet I'm also going to cancel this I'm
gonna cancel this big order so that guy
doesn't have to hold his breath and like
die down there
and then we're gonna build out tile
right here along this way down let me
just I gotta play it for a second and
then there we go alright so we're gonna
build tile all the way from there to
there and put that at a high priority
because what that's gonna do is it's
gonna dig out the algae that is there
and then hopefully they're gonna be able
to use that algae to be able to do
whatever they need to do like get these
running which which are still running so
there is some air scrubber happening but
the only problem is there's a lot of
other things that don't that don't have
what they need but we need to research
advanced filtration I am NOT going to
give up on these people because these
people literally are my family and so
when they build these tiles they're
actually going to remove all the rock
that's in the way first they're gonna
get the algae that is down there just
like that and then they're able to
collect it and then they'll build on top
of it so these things aren't gonna be
destroyed I will eventually remove that
outhouse and put it over in the compost
I don't know where they're putting
anything else there but these algae
terrariums are eventually working and
this guy's not doing well so what we
need is we need clean water we need
plumbing we need a shower we need good
beds we need massage tables we need
things for everybody to do and also we
need to get rid of this because this is
not doing anybody any good so once
that's done we have the basis for a room
and then we need to destroy this and
this this doesn't make any sense being
there we need to start we need to start
digging through this algae here we need
to collect this algae here
see can you build tile over that I don't
think so
but either way we're gonna build tile
there we're gonna make this make more
sense at the very base of it we do need
it we do eventually need to like
scrubbers down there so I'm thinking
algae terrariums would go down there too
just because just because it's not going
well for us up making a mess someone
just [ __ ] their pants
oh I'm sorry meep I'm sorry Oh God
you're [ __ ] right into the waterhole
oh sorry that's my fault I shouldn't
yell at you meep I'm sorry you're a good
kid
oh he's doing it again oh boy all right
at least that's getting done so in here
there's contaminated water admittedly
and I'd like to get that mopped up but I
just don't know where that's gonna mop
to so it's a daunting task but I'm up to
the challenge yes I am so I'm gonna make
here what I'm doing is this is gas
permeable tile so what that's gonna do
I'm not gonna put that there I'm gonna
put that gonna make sure the outsides
are lined with built tiles but straight
up and down throughout this whole place
I want there to be gas permeable tiles
so that oxygen can flow up and down
readily so this is all gonna go
eventually all this is gonna be
destroyed in the future and like
obviously that's not ideal but it is
what it is so what we also need here is
we probably need we need some sort of
power I guess we could put that there I
guess that's as good a place as any but
we do need oxygen like an algae
deoxidizer
we do need an algae terrarium here
probably there will be an okay place for
it and then we're gonna need power
manual generator it's already hooked up
to power and then we'll just put that up
to a tiny battery don't really need a
big one connect those across connect
those across and put these at a high
priority because we're gonna need oxygen
in this if we're gonna close it off
[Music]
let's welcome a new member of the family
I know it's probably irresponsible to
have people here scaredy cat can't
perform combat that's probably okay
grease monkey tinkering is good
Twinkletoes good athleticism
don't go toes an iron gut and loud
Snooper boy oh boy I'm gonna go with
Sookie come on Sookie urine I know it's
a bad place right now but hopefully
something soon this is gonna be a nice
place for you to live I don't know if
it's gonna be now but it's gonna be nice
some day boy so then down here
eventually I'm gonna dig down into the
water because we are running low on
water here and eventually what I'll have
to do is I will have to make a water
filtration system to get the
contaminated water to be to a point
where people can actually use it and I
know once again that there's a way to
turn water into oxygen I do know that
and we will get there eventually but for
now this is the best that we got and
what we got to deal with so let's just
let people be people and hopefully not
too much longer for the advanced
filtration to kick in they'll do their
thing we'll get that so we're gonna
hurry up I know it's not ideal to hurry
up in this point I wanted to take a I
want to pay very close attention to
everything going on here but time for
bed everybody time for bed do we have
enough beds for everybody
alright we're a full house up Natsuki
I'm sorry Sookie
that's just the way it goes sometimes I
apologize
I apologize I'm sorry I'm sorry to
everybody I'm sorry to everybody that
can't breathe down here we got people
lashing out but it's okay we've got food
it's [ __ ] food
I know it's [ __ ] food we got food we got
something other beating up on the [ __ ]
not the batter come on Lenny
god damn it Lenny I know you got a
attitude but we got to live here we got
a deal with this we got to do what we
can Lenny
we're gonna try we got a household of
ten now man if everybody keeps lashing
out they're not gonna have anything nice
come on someone put someone put algae in
that thing all right I gotta prioritize
this like these digs at least we gotta
get at least some algae out of here we
don't have a lot left eventually what I
have to do is I have to what I'll do is
I'll close off with an airlock the slime
area and these things these things
actually produce a steady stream of
slime and I shouldn't have killed it
because I need that because you can turn
slime into algae but also like slime can
be like slime continuously produces
contaminated oxygen it's not good but
it's still oxygen nonetheless so when
you have oxygen even if it's
contaminated you can purify the oxygen
through advanced filtration by using I
believe it was maybe I was wrong maybe I
was wrong maybe you can't turn
contaminated oxygen because you can
filter it out but that doesn't mean that
it's gonna pump out good oxygen Suze I'm
pretty sure yeah yeah it doesn't do
anything it doesn't oh no it doesn't
change it out you should at least we're
getting oxygen in here which is good and
then when the algae - oh boy did someone
just [ __ ] their pants again boy but this
is starting to take shape it's not a
hundred percent perfect and it won't be
for a while but at least it's starting
to take shape so when this goes up we're
gonna have another room here we need to
build a ladder like straight down to the
water because they can use it from the
they can use it from the tile there they
can use it from the ladder I believe oh
well at least we got mealworms okay time
for sleep you guys go beddy-bye I know
Sookie you don't have a bed but you
you're doing alright sookie sookie is
doing okay
I know Sookie like probably walked into
this and it's not very happy about
what's going on here but at least we'll
have oxygen in here we just don't have a
lot of we don't have a lot of it so
these oxygen things they consume an
absurd amount of algae like there's just
isn't enough algae in this entire area
to be able to sustain it but there's
oodles of slime there's just there's way
too much slime cuz if I were to compare
like the algae to the slime the slime is
just non-stop and these things just
constantly produce slime alright okay
good you're doing that stuff that's good
we've still got contaminated water there
I know that's not ideal oh man we got a
lot of it they've been [ __ ] their
pants non-stop over there right but it
looks like we're almost there on the
research front Gus is going for it Gus
is gonna get us the last bit of research
we'll be able to scrub carbon dioxide
out which is good because then we won't
have to rely entirely on the algae to
get rid of carbon dioxide because if we
run out of algae and we can't scrub the
carbon dioxide then we would die anyway
from suffocation but for now we're gonna
be okay
don't hit max max the one thing you
couldn't break
oh now Josie has to fix it yeah that's a
long repair too alright it's fine
we got the research we got what we
needed now we just worry about
combustion so that we got a lot of coal
I'm pretty sure around the place yeah
coal so we can make energy from that
that way people don't have to run as
much but I bet that producer pollution
or something so I'm gonna make a bold
move here but we got to make bold moves
if we're gonna be able to do anything in
life we got to get rid of all this [ __ ]
I know destroying that thing is gonna be
a problem because it's gonna spew all
the stuff that's inside it but we got to
deconstruct all this so that we can
construct all of this and then hopefully
we'll move through and be able to build
a new room here very quickly we'll get
there
we're getting there because I want this
side I want this side on the right here
to be ladder on the outside there
climbing but this is the interior
navigation I probably shouldn't have
that there that should probably be
outside let me just yeah that's that's
probably not a good idea to have that
there so then cancel that and destroy
that and then build an airlock there all
right
we'll build an airlock there tile up
there this way yeah okay they can't
reach it
missing foundation well obviously it's
missing a foundation but at least
they're getting some algae out of that
so that's good I know these guys now I
don't have beds again and it's even more
stressful than it was before but hey you
know what I'm doing the best I can
is trying to live life help my people
okay yep there's a bad night cuz not
everyone has a bed not just Sookie
anymore so hey maybe that's nice I did
this did say it was the uncomfortable
space prison so I don't think that you
guys should expect too much out of it
okay then deconstruct that gas permeable
Warhol olive holy [ __ ] that was quite
the vomiting okay so what we haven't Gus
I get it Gus I get it I get it I get it
I get it okay so we now need to make a
carbon dioxide scrubber and it's got to
be on the bottom we have we have one
algae terrarium down here and it's not
gonna be enough to get rid of all the
carbon dioxide because carbon dioxide
seems to fall comparative to anything
else is here I'm gonna put the
destruction order on these bad boys but
can we destroy this deconstruct
deconstruct and then in its place we're
gonna put something else we've got oh we
don't have a lot of food actually holy
[ __ ] we are low on food when did we get
that low on food I don't know when we
got that low on food but okay we're
gonna make food production over here
because apparently I don't have the
means to do anything else and also
carbon dioxide is being scrubbed
you're all ready so we're gonna have two
of these powering one big battery and
then we're gonna just have we could do
microbe crushers to mush bars and then
cooking stations to make them into
something more manageable and then
refrigerators to try to even it all out
I don't know if that's gonna be ideal
but maybe we only need one refrigerator
I'm not entirely sure about that but
then we need to connect all with power
okay so that should be okay right
and then since food is a priority card
these guys these so much to survive we
need to do that and then I guess just
one oxygen I know the algae terrarium
should be able to fill that small room I
mean it's it's a relatively small room
so I don't imagine that's gonna take
much more okay so that gas permeable
tile is down there that's good so people
can get in there that's good okay all
right good good good good good this is
going well it's not going great we need
to mop up this [ __ ] eventually cuz
that's just disgusting um we can make
this one the lavatory no we need to make
the lavatory area like a lower chamber
we can make this it for now
it's got algae terrarium it's not fun
and I I would like to make like good
plumbing you know but I'm thinking
thinking just outhouses for now down
here and then the compost compost put
that over there I guess dig this one out
make these relatively high priorities
ooh so I can get rid then I can get rid
of these and make the living area more
livable you know what I mean
cuz it's getting kind of disgusting here
it's shaping up it's shaping it's
shaping into something I don't know what
but it's shaping I may be totally wrong
about all my things I want to do here
but it's it's gonna be something it's
gotta be a whole lot of something whoa
new member of the family oh boy
whoo all over the place
Oh bad traits on you okay dan you're
gonna go for it okay so those are good
down there so now I can deconstruct this
and the compost here and get that the
Frick out of here I know olive olive I
know I know all of its no good I know
I'm well aware of that I know but anyway
they got this under way broken you broke
the one fit god damn it okay so we need
so these are gotta be like at least six
above normal priority but not like too
high oh there's so much stress I know
there's so much stress I'm well aware of
that fact
god dammit they're all broken ah
frickin dick all right time for bed I
think oh god they're not gonna be able
to breathe there oh they're gonna be
able to breathe very badly okay
[Music]
oh I know I know I know I know the
oxygen situation is pretty dire oh boy
why are you stressed vomiting everyone
here is stress vomiting oh boy oh boy
okay but but but but even though
absolutely every surface is covered in
vomit and puke and [ __ ] and even though
everyone is very unhappy and almost
everyone is at maximum stress I think
we're gonna survive this so I'm gonna
end this episode here it may seem dire
but this is actually going better than I
thought it was gonna go don't ask me how
cuz honestly I have no frickin clue I
really have no idea and we're just gonna
do the best that we can because
otherwise death is the only the only
other option and I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna die just not gonna
let him die so thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you guys are
enjoying this one they're gonna go to
bed in the few beds that they have
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]